what's up everybody
so something crazy has been spotted
today there is a huge Captain Marvel
Easter egg in Avengers infinity war or
what seems to be a huge easter egg real
fast just wanted to remind you about the
giveaway that I'm doing I'm giving away
a few copies of Avengers infinity war on
blu-ray and all you have to do to enter
is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
favorite superhero also if you want to
increase your chances of being able to
win a copy of Avengers infinity war
follow me on social media one of the
copies that I'm giving away it will be
solely chosen from my Instagram or
Twitter account so if you don't follow
me on there you should your chances will
probably higher because I don't have
that many followers yet okay about the
Captain Marvel Easter Egg take a look at
this still right here can you spot it
I'll give you a few seconds to take a
look did you happen to see it take a
look at Cole obsidian the big guy on the
left now do you see it
check out that banner that's hanging
from his waist that looks exactly like
Captain Marvel's uniform so this leaves
a question what the heck happened has he
fought her in the past did he defeat her
somehow or perhaps this is from Marvel's
uniform the first Captain Marvel but
that still leaves the same question has
he fought him in the past and did he
defeat him perhaps we're gonna see a
little cameo of the Black Order and
Captain Marvel when it comes out this
certainly makes you think so let me know
what you all think and let me know your
theory is in the comments below do you
think this is from Captain Marvel or
Marvel or do you think somehow it's from
something different let me know in the
comments below and again don't forget
about to giveaway all you have to do to
enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
favorite superhero you can also follow
me on social media thank you so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]
you